[MUSIC]
I'm Jesper Sorensen and I'm a professor
of organizational behavior at
the Stanford Graduate School of Business.
I teach a course called crafting and
leading strategy.
Here are five key
takeaways from that course.
[MUSIC]
We often think of strategists as
people who articulate grand visions,
draw up a blueprint, and
then tell their teams to make it happen.
That's wrong.
A strategy is a continually
evolving course of action,
not a monument to your genius.
The difference between architecture and
strategy is that while the ground
underneath a building rarely changes and
unforeseen ways, everything in
your world is subject to change.
And that means that you cannot simply do a
bunch of analysis, come up with an answer,
and then give people marching orders and
wait to see the results.
You need to think about
your strategy every day.
It is not a set it and
forget it kind of thing.
[MUSIC]
Executives around the world lack
confidence in their company's
strategies and
in their own strategy skills.
One big reason for this is that
they equate strategy with planning.
They believe that doing strategy requires
uniquely rare expertise and insights.
But as Glen Carol and
I argue in our book Making Great Strategy,
the core of any sustainably successful
strategy is a logically coherent argument,
a story about how actions and
investments lead to success.
We all engage in this kind of
reasoning in our daily lives.
But too often when it comes to strategy,
we forget to apply our reasoning
skills in a disciplined way.
Nobody knows your organization and
your market better than you.
All that stands between you and
a great strategy
is a disciplined reasoning that surfaces
the most critical drivers of success.
[MUSIC]
Some years ago I interviewed executives
at a large Silicon Valley company
to understand the challenges they were
facing with strategy and execution.
One executives said to me, the problem is
that we talk about the what not the why.
In other words, company leaders
would issue a to do list of sorts,
grow market share by 5%, cut costs by 10%,
invest more resources in marketing, etc.
But they were never clearly told
how these things fit together.
What the underlying logic of
action was supposed to be.
As a leader with a coherent strategy,
you have a method to your madness.
Your strategy is your unique
way of connecting the dots.
But if you only give people a to do list,
you force them to connect
the dots on their own.
It can get much more likely that they
will do something you do not want.
Instead, whenever you ask someone
to accomplish a specific objective,
always help them see how it
fits into the bigger story,
how it fits in the logic of your strategy.
[MUSIC]
As strategic leaders, we continually
strive to improve our strategy,
to find ways to improve our
organization's economic prosperity.
But how can we best do this?
The starting point is to embrace the idea
that your strategy is your theory of
success, or your belief about
how causes lead to effects and
how inputs lead to outputs.
But these theories only exist in the mind.
How do we know they are true or
worth pursuing?
Well, we can start by recognizing that
every time we act in accordance with our
strategy we are generating evidence.
Did our decision lead to
the consequences we expected?
If they did, we can feel more confident in
our strategy and sleep better at night,
at least for a while.
And if they did not,
we may need to rethink our strategy.
Fundamentally, every strategist should
think like a scientist, using evidence and
data to improve their understanding.
[MUSIC]
I like to ask students how they would
know whether they have a good strategy.
They'll debate this for a long time
talking about profit and growth and KPIs,
but it's a trick question.
The truth is you can never really be sure
that your success is due to your actions,
as opposed to factors beyond
your control or luck.
This messiness and uncertainty frustrates
many people when it comes to strategy,
but here's a different
way to think about it.
The uncertainty is the price
of discovery and greatness.
Our strategy is an expression
of how we think the world works.
But we should also embrace the idea that
doing strategy is a learning process,
that is an opportunity for us to
understand more about how the world works.
If we can embrace this uncertainty,
we'll be in a better position to
make the world a better place.
[MUSIC]
I wrote this book called
Making Great Strategy which my
adult kids love to make fun
of especially the title.
And so every time we now try to do
something like go to a restaurant or
talk about a problem in their job or
anything like that, they're like,
well, it's because they didn't
make a great strategy and
then they laugh laboriously,
and so on so forth.
And by the way, I think only one
of them has read the book, so.
[MUSIC]